historian Hanukkah is like a miracle
because I'm just like barfing up [ __ ]
everybody loves potatoes
everybody loves latkes my mouth is
already like salivate I know I'm so
hungry I just drilled them myself you
know I'm actually doing a service what
are you doing after this going to a lack
of money you there's lack of parties
yes Hanukkah so like in my experience it
is just okay I don't even need this this
is delicious
you can't go wrong it's just oily it's
like basically tater tots smushed down
applesauce and it's just so unorthodox
cuz lying about you come to my house and
you if I give you the mud and I'm like
just push a little siren okay hmm
I like this hour from a lot what are you
can is our friend Jewish food American
condiments American Jews the joys okay
what's next Jan no no no no way I'm
thinking about it you gave him peanut
butter
why remember the double down sandwich
from KFC know there's like chicken
something in between chicken but I'm
thinking lock PBJ lock gonna try it yeah
yeah new tradition see Latin folk Jewish
people we have the same hair texture a
lot of us are equally as Harry I'm super
Harry
oh hi I'm des beats the [ __ ] out of the
Eucharist oh my god you know that little
piece of Christ that you eat every
Sunday I mean I don't know I don't I'm
Jewish
what a good Jewish boy almost been a
great moment of cultural exchange you
guys
visits and I'm also glad that I have a
Jewish friend one